My wife and I found out earlier in the
year and we may not be able to have
children.
Then last month I was
diagnosed with cancer.
Okay.
Oh man,
how do I combat depression?
Well,
the first thing that we
should point out here,
I'm very sorry to hear about all that.
That's,
that's a lot of tragedy in
a very short period of time.
And,
um,
and I'm not going to give you
any casual advice because,
but I,
maybe I can make some things clearer.
The first is you're not depressed.
You've had terrible things happen to you.
That's not the same thing.
Right.
Okay.
I distinguished between them.
If a client comes to me and they say
they're feeling very sad and down and
anxious and worried about
everything and so forth,
then I kind of walked through their life.
Do they have friends?
Do they have a family?
Do they have a meaningful job?
It,
is their educational background
appropriate for their
level of intelligence and
ability?
Are they taking care of themselves?
Do they have something to look forward to?
Did they use their time outside
of work productively and wisely,
et cetera.
So you think about those as
the dimensions of a good life.
There's more,
or maybe there's fewer,
but that's not too bad for a quick
and dirty first pass through,
let's say.
Um,
those are the dimensions by the way,
that you work on.
If you do the future authoring
program in the self authoring suite,
you're asked to think about all those
dimensions and consider what your life
might be like if you
optimized along all of them.
And so,
um,
if you,
if all of those things are going well
for you and you feel terrible all the
time,
then you're depressed.
Okay.
Cause there's,
there's something wrong with
your emotional regulation.
You know,
I mean,
maybe you're having an existential
crisis that's a possibility,
but I mean,
let's assume we can't see anything
structurally wrong with your life,
but you're feeling terrible.
Then I would say,
well,
you have depression.
There's something wrong.
Maybe it's physiological
and people like that.
In my experience,
those are the people who often
really benefit from antidepressants.
But then there's other sort of
person who who is in trouble.
You know,
they,
their educational attainment
is not what it should be.
They don't have a job.
They have an alcohol or drug problem.
They have a family that's really not
functioning well or they don't have a
family.
Their immediate relationship,
intimate relationship is
nonexistent or terrible.
Um,
their friends are non existent or,
or,
or worthless and,
and destructive.
Um,
they don't get along with their relatives
there in poor mental and physical
health.
You get the picture that's,
and they're not feeling good.
There are moods low and they're anxious.
That's not depression.
Like it might be,
you know,
but it's a terror.
But what that is,
is a terrible life.
And,
and those are different
things they needed to be,
they need to be
conceptualized differently.
Now even if you have a terrible life,
an antidepressant might be able to
lift you up enough so that you can keep
fighting.
Let's say,
assuming that that's what you're doing,
but an antidepressant
obviously isn't going to help,
isn't going to remove the
facts of your terrible life.
Now you,
you've got terrible things
happening to you at the moment and,
and there's no simple answer to that.
I would say you could,
you could take a look at
chapter 12 in my book,
12 rules for life.
It's,
it's called a pet,
a cat when you encounter
one on the street.
And in part it's a,
it's an autobiography I autobiographical
chapter about how my wife and I and my
family,
my,
my son and daughter and my,
my extended family as well dealt with
my daughter's extremely serious illness
while she,
it's still,
it's still plagues are to some degree,
although not nearly as much as it did.
She was very seriously ill
when she was a teenager and a,
it was an ongoing crisis,
a continual for years of crisis.
And so the question is
how do you cope with that?
And the answer is,
the first answer is you
shrink your timeframe.
You know,
you've had these,
especially with regards to your diagnosis.
So like
all of a sudden your future has been
thrown completely into chaos and
you don't know how to deal with that.
And who would you do what you can to
stabilize your medical treatment and to
optimize your quality of
life while that's happening.
Very complicated thing to do.
And then I would say you live for the day,
you know,
for the week maybe,
maybe a week's too much even,
but for the day it's like
you get up in the morning,
you think I need to do everything I can
to make this day as meaningful and and
rich as I possibly can.
And hopefully I will have had a full day
by this evening and then I'll be able
to sleep and then I'll be able
to get up in the morning and say,
I'm going to try to make this day as
useful and meaningful and engaging as it
can be.
And then maybe when you're really sick,
you don't have a day,
you have hours and then you do
the same thing for the hours.
And then maybe you do the
same thing with the minutes.
I would also say,
you know,
you've been through a lot of shock and
it's conceivable that you might need to
talk to someone.
It's also conceivable that an
antidepressant could help you,
you know,
you've got a lot to deal with and you
might need your nervous system might need
some stabilization with all that stress.
And so that's something to consider.
Antidepressants are also quite
effective as pain medications,
especially a drug called.
So that's also worth knowing because
you need to know about effective pain
medication.
It's very important,
um,
in extreme situations of pain.
Opiates of course are the drug of choice,
but you could use drugs
like methylphenidate,
Ritalin,
the Adhd drug,
you can use them as adjuncts to,
to pain medication.
And people need to know that because the,
the,
um,
there basically amphetamines,
amphetamines have analgesic properties,
but they also keep,
they also maintain alertness.
And so the problem with opiates
is they can be sedating,
but an opiate amphetamine combination.
And this is for people who are
in absolutely intractable pain,
by the way,
um,
that can increase alertness
and help cope with pain.
And it's really useful to know what
you might need to cope with pain.
So I would say shrink your
time horizon and then,
oh,
thank you.
Okay,
thanks Tim.
Shrink your time horizon
and then concentrate on the
concentrate on the moment.
Whatever that moment happens to be,
might be the next minute,
you know?
I don't know what else to do when
you're in an extreme situation.
The other thing,
I guess the final thing I
would say with regards to the,
we may not have be able to have children.
Well,
you need a plan to address that to the
best that that you can to the best way
that you can.
And then you have to give yourself some
time to reconceptualize your life and
your future.
And I would say news,
like we may not be able to have children
that probably takes about a year or
year and a half to digest.
So don't be too hard on yourself
if you haven't figured it out yet.
It's any major life transformation,
like a really major life transformation.
I would say it takes a minimum
of a year to really adapt to.